yeah you mentioned that
like you kind of your reaction to it was
uh it
like it's something that you would love
to fly almost
uh so this object just the curiosity you
experience is like
like what it almost like what the heck
is that piece of technology and i want
to fly it
like what made you feel
like it's something that you could fly
do you think it's something that a human
could fly
like in terms of interpreting what you
saw as a piece of technology
because another perspective on it is it
was
uh not that the thing under the water
was the key thing and what you were
seeing
is some kind of projection or something
that like
i don't think it was a projection i
think it was a real object it was a
physical hard object
that you could be flied oh yeah yeah i
think
all four of us will say the same thing
it wasn't it wasn't this was not because
you go
okay let's just go on it's a light
projection
well if we were both sitting next to
each other we were looking at it from
the exact same angle and all that and i
go oh okay there's a
in theory you could have that but with
an 8 000 foot altitude difference flying
you know and there
you know she's probably not directly
above me she's kind of hanging out
watching this whole thing happen
you know you're getting two different
perspectives from two different
altitudes over a clear blue
you know if you've ever been at sea and
i don't mean like coastal i mean like
when you get out at sea the ocean is the
bluest it's incredible
um you know you got a bright white
object over a deep blue ocean
you got pretty high contrast and for
this thing just to disappear
uh it's it's was i'm telling you i would
i mean i know we we all have the same
uh recollection of what happened you
know there's some details because it's
so long ago but
for the most part we know what we saw
and we all came back and looked at each
other like what the hell was that what
if
i mean do you think about the thing
under the water that's not often talked
about
if there's something under the water
couldn't have been something gigantic
like it could be what like do you ever
see this
big ship that's why as a person so i
love like swimming out into the ocean my
mom's an olympic swimmer so like
i love that feeling but i'm also
terrified when i swim because the abyss
it could anything could be under there
i like there's not enough focus
on that perhaps because there's no
visibility but is it
is there anything interesting to say
about the possibility there was anything
underneath there it could be i mean
think about if you're going to hide
on this planet where's
what's the least explored spot on the
planet two-thirds of it's the ocean
you there's there's there's literally i
mean come on
the the the malaysia airplane the the
triple seven it was a triple seven that
crashed you know they turned
they didn't go where they're supposed to
and they just disappeared and they've
been searching for it and they found
pieces of it
but you would think there's large
objects that you know when that thing
hit the water
depending on how it broke up there's big
pieces that would be you'd find
something they haven't found anything
except what floated
um so to hide something underwater i
think would be
easy
you